so i asked ant-man the other day if he
had changed for a dollar
you know what he said to me sorry i'm a
bit
short
you suck
hello internet welcome to film theory
where
thank goodness our science is better
than our jokes
so uh marvel they're kind of a big deal
huh i mean i guess it's fair to say
since they've redefined comic book
movies made mega stars out of unknown
characters and completely
changed the way we watch movies not too
bad but even with all their successes
i would say ant-man may be one of their
biggest
sure avengers was game changing and
guardians was an
instant smash but ant-man literally had
nothing going for it not even a snarky
raccoon i mean
seriously ant-man the character isn't
unknown the production was a mess and
even the trailer was just
kind of generic honestly i went to see
it simply because you can only play
solitaire for so long before the
loneliness starts to weigh on your cold
dead heart
forever alone but crippling loneliness
be darned i was blown away
the characters were lovable the action
was so so clever
and it gave me a newfound respect for
baskin robbins baskin robbins always
finds out
but topping that sweet sweet 31 flavor
ice cream sundae was the delicious
cherry
of science because in trying to come up
with a perfectly valid explanation for
ant-man's ability to shrink and grow
marvel without realizing it created the
strongest
most devastating superhero in their
on-screen universe thus far
had the events of the movie been real
ant-man would have destroyed
the planet it's a detailed marvel
overlooked but like baskin robbins
i always find out so scott lang the
ant-man has the ability to shrink
and increase in size this is explained
through the use of pym
particles a rare group of subatomic
particles that shrink or increase the
distance between
atoms or the distance between parts of
the atom now that may
sound crazy but the scientific basis is
totally
plausible you know how everything around
you is made of atoms well atoms are
mostly made of
empty space take for instance the
hydrogen atom which is roughly
99.99999999996
percent empty that is a lot of nines
which brings us to a mind-blowing fact
if you were to squeeze
all of the space out of the atoms in the
human body
you could fit the particles of the
entire human race
inside of a sugar cube all of humanity's
particles could exist in a volume that
small
sweet literally which obviously begs the
question
if your body is made of mostly empty
space why can't your hand
pass through the computer screen well
how do you know have you tried it now
that you know the truth seriously reach
out touch the screen
you just gotta believe
that i'm obviously trolling you stop
smudging your screen of course your hand
can't pass through it you think watching
a youtube video is gonna change
decades worth of physics that you know
from personal experience i appreciate
your faith in me
but sadly i do not yet have the ability
to bend physical realities of
reality but that being said here's a
crazy thing in the moment of you
touching the screen you weren't
actually touching it the chair you're
sitting on not touching that either
you're hovering
on top of it the electrons of the chair
are repelling the electrons of your butt
negative charges are repelling each
other that's why despite being mostly
empty space
all you over eager youngsters aren't
going to be able to phase through the
walls of the girls locker room anytime
soon
how dare you respect their privacy but
what it does mean is that in theory
if pim particles could increase or
decrease the distance between atoms
they could feasibly work the fake
science makes sense
almost the movie explicitly states that
pym particles only change the distance
between
atoms they don't actually change the
number of atoms
what that means is that when they change
the size of an object
the mass stays the same mass aka the
quantity of matter the object has
aka the number of atoms so if scott's
mass stays the same but his volume is
either shrinking or expanding
what's really changing is his density
density equals mass divided by volume
and messing with this
completely changes all the events that
you see in the movie
including giving scott the ability to
destroy the planet
let's break it down take for instance
the multiple times pym particles are
used to increase the size of objects the
two that immediately popped in mind for
me are the giant ant and the thomas the
tank engine toy
these moments near the end of the movie
were unexpected and absolutely hilarious
some of the most creative humor i've
seen in a movie in a long time
but the real life physics would have
made them even more
ridiculous on average ants only tend to
have a mass of about three milligrams
but the pym
particles now expand those three
milligrams of mass
to a volume the size of a human which is
about 66.4
liters 67.4 if you include my daily
liter of diet coke throwing that into d
equals mv means that the density of the
ant would be at .04 milligrams per liter
what's that mean well consider this the
density of
air is 1200 milligrams per liter
that ant would be lighter than air he
would literally float away
like a giant creepy ant balloon the same
would hold true for the giant thomas the
tank engine forget bursting through the
house and crushing that cop car the
thing would just drift away like a
bouncy castle caught in a breeze
by the way that sort of thing has
actually been a pretty serious problem
around the country not rogue thomas the
tank engines but bouncy castles on the
breeze
in 2011 alone at least 10 bouncy castles
either floated away or collapsed because
they weren't properly tied up
injuring more than 40 people it's like a
twisted version
of up so parents remember
guns don't kill people
this public service announcement is
brought to you by the film theorist
council for public safety
long story short haphazardly tossing
those enlarging shurikens around would
result in some pretty bizarre balloon
creatures
and of course the opposite effect would
also occur if you took something big and
heavy and used pym particles to make it
a lot smaller
say for instance a tank on a keychain
perhaps after doing the research the
particular tank hank pym uses as a
keychain was a t-34
soviet combat vehicle weighing in at
approximately 26.5
tons i don't think i really need to
explain how that much weight on a key
chain might be a bit tough to tote
around probably ruining a pair of pants
or two if you kept it in your pocket
however the tank wouldn't be the only
thing that'd be a problem if it was
shrunken down like in the film
so would our lovable hero scott lang
throughout the movie scott takes
advantage of his new size to sneak into
several places whether it be by riding
on ants or hiding in clothing
or whatever okay so let's say that scott
weighs roughly 200 pounds of pure paul
rudd muscle
there would be absolutely no way antony
or any of the other ants for that matter
would be able to support that amount of
weight
i mean ants are able to lift five
thousand times their own mass
don't get me wrong but when your mass is
only three milligrams
that's still just 15 grams scott
at 200 pounds would have a mass of
roughly 90
000 grams he would squish him long
before they entered battle
and forget all those scenes where
ant-man is climbing on people or lands
on their gun
or whatever putting that much weight on
a small surface area could have some
pretty devastating consequences
the movie briefly toys with this idea
when scott first changes into the suit
and tests it out
he falls out of the bathtub and when he
lands on the tiles of the bathroom floor
you can see them visibly crack under his
weight they then promptly forget this
little scientific detail but
now imagine that scott punches a dude in
the face when he's the size of an
ant because his fist would be a super
dense ball of mass
focused in an incredibly tiny surface
area his hand would be like the point of
a knife or a needle
easily breaking through the skin of his
enemies if he ran and jumped at someone
there's a high likelihood that he'd
function
just like a bullet a dense ball of mass
shooting his way
through his enemy but that's not even
scratching the surface of scott's true
power
now we're at the true insanity of what
he can do
at the end of the movie scott must turn
off his suits regulator the device that
protects him from shrinking too
small in order to squeeze between the
molecules of yellow jacket's power pack
he does this so he can save his daughter
but in doing so get this he would have
created
a black hole now whenever you think of
black holes
images of giant planet-eating tears in
space-time probably come to mind
stars that have died and collapsed in on
themselves bodies with
unimaginable mass however any amount of
mass can actually become a black hole
if it becomes dense enough this is
illustrated in a concept
known as the schwarz child radius
basically this is the radius of a sphere
that if
all the mass of an object were
compressed within that sphere the escape
velocity from it would equal the speed
of light
everything within this radius becomes a
black hole
so i did the calculations and assuming
that scott weighs right around 200
pounds and has a mass of roughly 90
kilograms he would achieve enough
density to become a black hole
if he was shrunken down to a radius of
roughly 1.3
times 10 to the negative 22nd
millimeters
which is tiny in the film scott turns
off his suit safety switch and shrinks
down
quickly shrinking past cells and
molecules we then see him shrink past
the size of an atom but even then he's
not
small enough but lucky for us he keeps
going
from the way this scene is designed he
gets smaller than quarks which is an
elementary particle
i.e particles that aren't made up of any
other smaller
substance at least we haven't yet
identified what those smaller substances
are quarks are the pieces that make up
protons and neutrons
but he gets smaller yet by the time he
finally stops shrinking he's surrounded
by these weird
flat crystal-like structures kind of
like fractals or a super trippy screen
saver now it's unclear what exactly they
are but from their design they appear to
be an artistic rendering of strings
from string theory it's a long story
what exactly they are and it's better
left to another theory
so let's just say this between them and
quarks scott at this point
is really really small as small as 10 to
the negative
30 second millimeters which considering
his mass
is small enough to create the density we
need
to form a black hole and here's the
really fun part
this wouldn't be a mini black hole that
would dissipate in a fraction of a
second
this would in fact be a very viable
black hole
black holes decay by a process known as
hawking radiation
named after stephen hawking as you can
imagine the more mass the black hole has
the longer it can stay
viable and start sucking in more mass to
grow according to medium.com the least
amount of mass that a black hole could
stay viable with
is point zero zero zero zero two
grams but remember we have nearly 200
pounds of sexy pull rudd to feed our
little baby black hole
giving it plenty of mass to survive
hawking radiation decay and plenty of
time to start sucking in particles from
around it
eventually growing so large it would
swallow the world as we know it the
brutal irony here is that in trying to
save his daughter's life
scott lang would have doomed not just
her life but the entire
planet including all her ant balloons
and tank
keychains so suck on that thor even your
godlike powers are no match
for the ant-man is it too late to change
the name
but hey that's just a theory
a film theory and cut
oh and i should mention that the movie's
ending overlooks the fact that scots
atoms can't actually shrink smaller than
atoms themselves
if pym particles are just reducing the
space between atoms then the size scotch
shrinks to is actually impossible based
on the explanation you receive in the
movie
he's still made of atoms the particles
themselves aren't shrinking
it's the space between them that is
meaning
that he can't get to those crazy small
sizes sorry marvel
you are better off sticking with the
explanation from the comic books